حسنًا ، لقد طرحنا قضية
دعم PYD YPG من قبل
الأمريكيين باسم محاربة داعش أو - منذ
شهور حتى الآن في الواقع منذ سنوات تقريبًا
ولم نتلق أي
إجابات مقنعة بنتائج إيجابية
من الجانب الأمريكي أو
من بلدان أخرى في
المنطقة ، السبب الذي دفعنا إلى اتخاذ هذا الإجراء هو
بالتحديد بسبب أمننا القومي
على طول حدودنا ،
كان هناك عدد من الهجمات في الواقع
على مدار العام الماضي أو ما
يقرب من 700 هجوم من هذه المنطقة الخاضعة للسيطرة
من قبل PYD YPG وكانت هناك
عمليات عبر الحدود من كلا الجانبين
وما إلى ذلك ، لذا فقد أثارنا هذه المسألة
عدة مرات وفي
نهاية اليوم بالطبع حتى تعلم أنه كان علينا
اتخاذ إجراءات لحماية حدودنا وكذلك
أنت تعرف أن ذروة حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي ووحدات حماية الشعب هي فرع حزب العمال الكردستاني في سوريا
وأن حزب العمال الكردستاني هو الذي تم إدراجه
كمنظمة إرهابية في كل من أوروبا
والولايات المتحدة ولا يمكننا السماح
لهذا النوع من التنظيم الإرهابي
بإنشاء نوع من الحكم الذاتي  أو
هيكل الدولة على طول حدودنا ،
لذا فإن الاختصارات التي تتحدث عنها
تشير إلى أسماء هذه
المجموعات الكردية التي يدعم بعضها من قبل
الولايات المتحدة ، لكن هل سيؤدي ذلك إلى تقويض
حلفاء الناتو ضد بعضهم البعض ، أعني
ما هي الإجراءات التي تتخذها  إذا كنت تأخذ أي شيء
للتأكد من عدم دخولك في حرب ساخنة
مع حليفك الرئيسي في الناتو ، فالولايات
المتحدة أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، الأمريكيون
ليسوا في منطقة عفرين ، فهم
في الغالب في منطقة الرجال العاهرة الموجودة
هناك إلى الشرق  عن نهر الفرات ،
نحن نتحدث عن الجانب الغربي
من البلاد عبر الحدود التركية
رقم اثنين بالطبع نقوم
بتنسيق هذه العمليات في جميع
الفروع التي أطلعنا
حلفاءنا على إحاطة الدول الخمس التابعة للأمم المتحدة
التي تحدث رئيسنا عنها للتو مع
الرئيس ماكرون  سيتحدث إلى
الرئيس بوتين وسيتحدث أيضًا
إلى الرئيس ترامب غدًا
وقد فعلنا ذلك في جميع
الأوساط الدبلوماسية للتأكد من أن
الجميع يفهم  ما نقوم به
نحن نتحلى بالشفافية في هذا الأمر
لأنك تعلم أن أمننا القومي
على المحك ،
دعني أؤكد أيضًا أن
هذه ليست عملية مسيحية ضد
لعنة عفرين أو سوريا ، إنها
عملية ضد
شبكة إرهابية تدعي أنها تمثل
الأكراد ولكن هذا بعيد كل البعد عن الحقيقة
لأن هناك الآلاف من الأكراد الذين
لا يشاركون في قضية حزب العمال أو من خلال هذه
الأيديولوجية الماركسية اللينينية
ولديك واحدة من أعظم المفارقات في
التاريخ الحديث حيث
اختارت الحكومة الأمريكية منظمة ماركسية
لينينية  كحليف لها في سوريا